the National Geographic Channel
celebrates the dog whisperers 100th
episode with a dog on off the bone
partay
and the guest list includes all the
stars of the show
Cesar Millan the owners kiss help train
and the dogs he's rehabilitated every
Batman needs a Robin and for Cesar his
constant companion daddy has helped
shatter myths and misconceptions about
dogs my daddy especially when it comes
to pitbulls
play that that's mine mine when I
brought that into the picture I just saw
a normal dog come on that is just
inspire and motivate her to move forward
you're seeing for daddy some thanks a
Bixel interval of daddy with secret
weapon
oh he's happy now he's happy now let's
try wow that it once again save the day
he's playing with this we gotta play the
game you know the first
and my whole life since daddy is nearing
retirement he's preparing to pass the
torch to a new generation and actually
this is Todd jr. I just want to
introduce you to jr. that is 40 years
old and I saw this as my cell you know
you get to the end of your life and you
will always be with us and with me but
jr. is learning from daddy to be the
greatest pit bull on earth all new
episodes of The Dog Whisperer every
Friday night at 9:00
only on Nat Geo